This is the camera that changes photography.
And this is the phone that changes mobile.
Introducing Galaxy S20 Ultra.
Our camera brings 8K video resolution to photos...
...and we've built a game-changing 5G phone around it.
At the heart sits our AI pro-grade camera system, with 9x more pixels than most cameras.
That means you can forget about 12 megapixels...
...because with epic 108MP photos you can now pinch in, and in...
...then you can take another photo from that and it will still be pin-sharp.
And when it comes to zoom, Space Zoom will take you places no mobile has been before.
You can now zoom 10x or an unbelievable 100x.
And when it comes to action,...
...S20 Ultra brings true action-cam to mobile.
Our 8k expertise now comes to mobile.
8K Video Snap will forever change photography.
With a 5G phone built around the camera,...
...you can now share all your 8K videos on YouTube.
S20 Ultra's Intelligent Battery management gives you the power to go on and on and on.
Thanks to storage going up to 1.5 terabytes,...
...there's room to store all 750,000 of your favorite photos.
Today, our AI pro-grade camera system changes how you capture photos and videos.
And we've built three game-changing 5G phones around it that change mobile.
Introducing Galaxy S20 Ultra.